otra masacre penitenciaria en Ecuador al
menos 10 presos murieron asesinados en
la cárcel el inca de quito el episodio
se dio después de que la policía
intentara trasladar a Jonathan Bermúdez
cabecilla de la temida Banda criminal
Los Lobos a un centro de máxima
seguridad en Guayaquil en la
particularidad
ni de armas de fuego ni de armas blancos
sino Aparentemente la la causa de muerte
sería el primer año decenas de reclusos
fueron maniatados para evitar que
opusieran resistencia al traslado de
Bermúdez quienes acusado de liderar una
matanza similar que dejó cinco muertos
el 7 de noviembre cuando las autoridades
decidieron mover a más de mil reclusos a
otros centros penitenciarios
la crisis carcelaria en Ecuador suma
alrededor de 400 muertos durante 15
masacres producidas desde febrero de
2021 en un intento por frenar la crisis
el gobierno anunció su nuevo estado de
emergencia y emprendió el traslado de
los presos considerados más peligrosos a
nuevas instalaciones Desatando mayores
solas de violencia la fiscalía anunció
la apertura de una investigación para
esclarecer los detalles de este último
motivo luego de sendas incursiones
exitosas en la cárcel del inca en Quito
y la cárcel de Bellavista en Santo
Domingo las fuerzas de seguridad del
Estado controlaron a los ppl y
extrajeron a los cabecillas era muy
importante movilizarlos no solo para
reducir las posibilidades de más
disturbios en las cárceles sino también
en las calles en las últimas semanas el
presidente Guillermo lasso ha anunciado
mejoras en los centros penitenciarios
del país e intentos de diálogo con las
bandas criminales mientras muchos de sus
los comentarios son acusados de
corrupción